let's start this way so the title uh
leave the gun take the cannoli that
jumps out at anybody who's ever seen the
godfather which should be everyone was
that your title from the from the get-go
well it was one of the it was one of the
best ones of course because it's one of
the greatest ad-libs of all time you
know when uh clemenza uh after they
shoot the turncoat polygato in the
shadow of the statue of liberty uh
says that a mortal line you know and it
was a total ad-lib and so it was just
kind of represented the serendipity the
the unlikeliness the the movie that
everybody thought was not going to be a
success and just like that title just
like clemenza's word it it words it
turned out to be one of the greatest of
all time
you've been zeroing in on this it's kind
of been on your front burner for a long
time is this sort of your great white
whale i mean you've written other stuff
successful great stories and books uh
but is this
the one
well you know i think i'm i'm one of
legions of godfather fanatics you know
all over the world and i've always been
obsessed with the movie since i wrote a
story uh well i've been obsessed with
the movie since i saw it as a college
freshman in 1972 but in 2008 i was lucky
enough to be assigned
by
vanity fair magazine to write a story
about the making of the godfather and so
i was able to meet a lot of the players
then and feed my obsession
well it's you know it's remarkable what
separates your book from as you said and
you write in your book there's a lot
that's been written about the godfather
about puzo and the making of the movie
but you had access i mean you got access
to people who are now long gone
exactly like the great the late great
robert evans uh
invited me into his home and uh we
watched parts of the movie together uh
in his bed in his bed right exactly he
he watched movies in bed and he said you
know let's go in there and we're going
to watch the booby and so we laid on his
bed and watched the godfather or at
least parts of the godfather while he
told me the story uh of uh of the making
of the godfather and so that was a uh
a great afternoon his screening room was
out of order and so from that point on
he and his friends watch movies in his
bed
what a character i mean larger than life
you know i haven't read his
autobiography i'm going to uh it's one
of those things that's on the list but
gosh he could be a subject of a movie
himself oh my gosh yes he was he was the
subject of that documentary the kid
stays in the picture that was based on
his book and you just you know he was
the man who green lit the movie who uh
you know they hired the
author mario puzo to write the
screenplay before francis coppola came
along and then he fought
for every aspect of the movie as he
writes uh you know spending way too much
time on the godfather but he always said
robert evans always said he wanted to
touch magic which i think he did in this
film so much of what you chronicle here
it comes to down to one word is
improbable i mean it's improbable that a
lovable schlub like mario puzo would
write such a massive and massively
successful novel that paramount would
produce it that evans would be in charge
of production that that coppola would
get to direct it all the cast members as
you chronicle there you know all of them
there were problems and barriers put up
to any of this happening it's it's
incredible it was ever made at all it
really is because they did paramount did
not want to make the picture in the
beginning mom movies just did not play
they had made a film called the
brotherhood which was critically fairly
well received but it bombed at the box
office so they weren't real keen on
making the movie but there was one thing
mario puzo's novel the godfather was
shooting up the best seller list and so
they had to make it or bert lancaster
wanted to buy the pic the project from
paramount and danny thomas wanted to buy
the studio to to get to buy the studio
to make the godfather himself and
probably star in it and uh paramount had
to make the film at that point
uh talk to us about mario puzo so you
got to know him doing all this research
and the people around him the fact that
he never really actually met a real-life
mobster i guess he did later but yeah
growing up uh you know you would think
that as a degenerate or at least
inveterate gambler like him would come
across mob guys but you say he didn't
well he always said he never met a
genuine gangster but he grew up around
him all his life because he was a child
of hell's kitchen
and uh you know the the mob uh influence
was there and he met men that were
shadowy and uh but he never knew who
they were and what they were doing but
you know one threw a blanket full of
guns into their living room and asked
his mother
to keep them forth for him so he's
around these men and he knew their world
and he he he was a down and out writer
he had written two
novels both of which were critically
well received but commercially
unsuccessful i think he got three
thousand dollars advance on each of them
and one of the and he was trying to sell
his third book and and the publisher
said
one publisher said if only there had
been a little bit more of that mob stuff
he had a mobster in one of his books
maybe he'd be successful and so he
decided
he wasn't going to write for art anymore
he was going to write for money and i
can tell you the story of the gutter
story if you'd like yeah sure yep so
what the turning point in the mario puzo
is the hero of the story he was he came
from hell's kitchen
and uh he had a family of five that he
was trying to support but he had a
gambling habit he was low on money he
was borrowing money right and left from
family bookmakers
everyone else and finally one night he
had a severe gallbladder attack and
he directed the taxi to take him to the
va hospital in new york and as soon as
he arrived at the hospital the pain
struck so bad he opened the door he fell
out of the taxi and into a gutter
and he was laying on his back in the
gutter looking up at the night sky and
he said as he later said joe later wrote
here i am a published author and i'm
dying like a dog and he said it was that
point where i decided i'm going to be
rich and famous and he did
at that time in that period before the
success of the godfather he's writing
for these tawdry men's magazines
and none of it would be considered art
but he really was banging out a lot of
copy that honed his skills
he was the greatest pulp fiction writer
they said of all time he was writing for
this collection of men's magazines
mostly but he could create these amazing
worlds uh that he everybody would take
to be real and that's where he learned
his craft he learned
he learned to write a story where all
the main characters were introduced in
the beginning just like the game the
godfather all the main characters are
introduced in the wedding he also
learned to write in a style that kept
readers turning the pages
and he also included that he thought
that because sex sells he needed to have
a lot of sex in his books and his
articles
and he just became this great pulp
fiction writer and the godfather novel
has many of those traits
you
what comes across as you writing about
him is that you like the guy i mean you
you admire him to some extent he is kind
of lovable a big heart
uh he maybe isn't a degenerate gambler
but certainly gambling gets him into
trouble keeps him broke a lot but
you know he pays his debts he
there's a certain honor code with him
right
well you have to root for mario puzo and
i found myself rooting for him every
step of the way i was so lucky to be
able to look at his archives which are
at dartmouth dartmouth
university and they have letters where
he writes to the irs you know i have a
book a book advance coming up and i'll
be able to pay my taxes uh you know once
that comes through you can see his
struggles you can see he writes in this
red pen
uh felt pen where you can see the notes
the outline the characters the godfather
being born and there he is you know this
this man this author that everybody
thought as he said himself he was the
chooch of the family you know nobody
expected him to amount to a lot and here
he is he writes he just creates this
best seller you know the kefauver
hearings which stopped through las vegas
were captivating americans in the 50s it
was the first time the mob was really
exposed on national television it was a
sensation
and mario puzzle was laying on his couch
in the suburb suburbs of new york
watching along with everybody else but
what he did is he took this factual
world and he created a world that was
even more dramatic more violent not
maybe not as violent maybe not more
violent but more gripping than any uh he
created faction
he created
fiction that the world would take as
fact
he shopped it around no one was
interested he finally uh go keeps
working plugs away he calls his book the
godfather which the publisher didn't
like that title right that's right
that's what they didn't like they hated
the title i was told
that's unbelievable but he finally gets
a rough draft and turns it in and he
goes off the to europe for a vacation he
can't afford and just figures well you
know cast his fate to the winds comes
back and what does he learn when he gets
back yeah so he goes on a vacation with
his family to europe because he promised
his wife who was born in germany that he
would take her back
she hadn't been back since the war and
he takes his kids and they go over to
europe and he gambles at every casino on
the riviera and in london and he's
taking money off of his american express
credit cards and everything else and
he's broke he's even more broke when he
comes back he calls his agent thinking
she could pull a slick magazine story
out of her hat like she'd done to rescue
him in the past and she goes you won't
believe it uh the book that you left us
with he had told them not to show the
book to anybody because it needed to be
polished uh we've just had an offer up
for 400 000 dollars which was then an
advantage a record for an advance but
from a paperback house
suddenly mario puzo was a rich beyond
his wildest dreams as you write in the
book he tries to tell his wife and other
people hey i just got offered this 400
grand or 410 or whatever it was for this
book and and it doesn't sink in does it
nobody believes him yeah he had written
about this in his own memoir uh he said
he called his mother and she and she
misunderstood she thought it was 40 000
which would have been great you know
because he only got 3 000 for his last
book and so that would have been a a
world you know windfall and then
he had to say no mom it was four hundred
and ten thousand dollars and he said he
took the check to to the bank to the
teller that it always kind of like
looked at him and you know kind of like
in
disparaging way because he was you know
covered his checks and whatever and he
all of a sudden he has 410 000 or
whatever a piece of that to to deposit
i think some of the best stories you
write are about how he
found inspiration and how he
incorporated real life events into
mobster lore i mean you mentioned about
the bag of guns that was thrown in their
apartment that becomes a scene i think
in in godfather too right
yes yeah so he he'd been around all
these these men all of his life he knew
their stories he had watched the
hearings he was able to to take
the any
the other thing that mario was great at
was reading he was just he was a
voracious reader and so he read about
these men and their worlds and he was
able to create
the secret to the godfather it's not
just about criminals it's not just about
gangsters it's about a family the family
corleone and he was able to create this
world with don corleone as francis
coppola said he saw it not as a gang
story of gangsters but the story of a
king and his three sons and that's what
puzzle saw and that's what puzzle
created
you write that a lot of the uh
mannerisms or sayings came from his mom
that later became part of don corleone's
character
exactly yeah he said a lot of those
famous lines from from don corleone came
from his mother's lips like you know a
man who doesn't spend time with his
family can never be a real man uh you
know
many of the the great classic lines from
from the don came from his mother uh who
was a very you know top uh
italian-american mom
who um you know just led her family uh
and created this incredible writer mario
puzo the first writer ever to come out
of the family and look what happened and
look who he became a lot of the research
he did was here in my hometown las vegas
of course it would be mecca for somebody
like puzzo a inventor at gambler he came
here and i don't know if these are true
stories do you believe them that he
he learned he conducted interviews at
the roulette wheel and would pick up
bits and pieces from pit bosses that's
what i was told that's what i was told
that he that he came to las vegas well
of course we know he came to las vegas
his las vegas was he loved las vegas he
wrote a book about las vegas he said you
know
his idea of heaven was a pit boss of the
sky and you know a casino he was a he
loved to gamble and las vegas was home
away from home his assistant said that
whenever you know they were heading to
the studio
at some point
he would say okay get on the 405 and she
knew what that meant we're taking the
first plane to las vegas and he stayed
at the sands and the flamingo i believe
and
i was told by um
by people in las vegas that he that he
did learn
uh
about many of the the characters that he
modeled his family and and and the men
that worked for the family after some
real-life people that uh that he that he
learned about in las vegas he's at the
sands as you right and he's peppering
people with questions they're a little
bit suspicious about him and what his
motives are what he's up to but he does
get some pretty good information i think
carl cohen is one of his sources the guy
who has smashed out frank sinatra's
teeth
and and one of the lines that came from
cohen is i made him an offer he can't
refuse right yeah that's what i was i
was told that one night uh there was uh
someone disorderly in the casino
carl cohen subdued him and uh somebody
said well how did you do it he goes i
made him an offer he couldn't refuse
it was david jansen the actor right back
yes so he picks up this these tidbits in
las vegas weaves them into the story he
was also asking about sinatra and he of
course in the book is a very thinly
veiled character in the book in the
movie um based on sinatra and sinatra as
you write was not happy about it at all
he met puzzle in a restaurant right
exactly he met they met in jason's which
was the hollywood restaurant those in
those days and and puzzle and al ruddy
the producer of the godfather went into
chasing's and puzzle later wrote that
sinatra was standing there with john
wayne and he did he wasn't the down and
out sinatra that johnny fontaine was
this was a man who looked like looked
like you know a million bucks and he was
standing there with john wayne and
uh already the producer said you know he
knew that sinatra wasn't happy with the
portrayal of johnny fontaine even though
he wasn't named frank sinatra but it
looked it looked a lot similar traits he
said let's take a wide turn and so uh
they went to the other side of the
restaurant and someone brought him over
broke mario over to meet frank sinatra
thinking sinatra would like it and from
that point on there was fireworks in the
restaurant almost led to uh there were
threats of physical dot violence and
it was quite an explosive scene so
sinatra hated the book he certainly
didn't want a movie to be made out of it
a lot of people didn't want it to become
a movie after it was on the best seller
lists forever um but it got done as
improbable as it was and then later you
write the book that sinatra changed his
opinion that he
he made an offer that maybe he should be
the godfather yeah that was that was
that's been told that uh he went to the
director francis confluence and maybe
you and i should do it myself and maybe
he could play the godfather but who
knows as i write in the book there's a
million stories around the godfather
some of them are conflicting some of
them uh you know are a little bit
strange but you know that's what makes a
great story about us about the making of
a movie i think is that so many uh
different stories about this movie it
has its own folklore it has its own
magic it has its own momentum and it's
just uh the the tale behind the movie is
i think almost as almost as compelling
as the movie itself you hear conflicting
stories about how mobsters reacted to
the book
yeah in general though it sounds like
they loved they loved the portrayal and
their their mysterious world and men of
honor
oh yeah after the after the book came
out
really after the movie came out puzzle
uh
writes wrote in a in an old newspaper
article i read that uh the mob there was
a
rumor going around that he was paid a
million dollars or something you know
all the all these crazy stories uh that
the mob loved the
the uh the the movie so much that that
they were behind it which they obviously
they weren't um that um that he um
you know that he was this is true that
he would go to restaurants and and the
waiter would come over and say you know
a bottle of champagne would arrive or
whatever and said it's a certain party's
pleasure another um another member of
one family told a new york times writer
that they loved the movie that they felt
that puzzle had to have some kind of
inside information into their world that
he got him down to right it was too
perfect but of course he was he was a
guy in a in a suburban new york basement
with a typewriter and a dream and he
dreamed it all up yeah sammy the bull
gravano you quote him in the books and
he must have had an inside source or
something
even though i mean you could make an
argument whether this is an accurate
portrayal of the mob or not it's sort of
a glamorous
glamorous portrayal totally glamorous
yeah it's it's it's a movie you know
it's but it but it's a movie that that
just has become myth you know it is it's
a very glamorized uh story and it's a
very glam you know even the wedding i
mean i'm sure that uh there's weddings
like that with 750 p you know people as
extras and they're you know throwing
sandwiches and clemenza's drinking wine
from the bottle
from the jug as puzzle wrote in this
novel while he's blowing like a whale
and you know johnny fontaine or comes in
and serenades the crowd i mean he's just
over the top uh glamour you're right
it's just very glamorous portrayal of
maybe what's not such a glamorous world
and although the mobsters seem to like
the book and that portrayal when the
movie gets going there are a lot of
problems a lot of threats
very serious threats right
yes because in those days in the early
70s well the studio uh you know first
they wanted to film in kansas city or st
louis because new york was the most
expensive town to film in and they
wanted to make it current day because
period is also very expensive but
coppola insisted on new york and once
they got to new york
even before they got to new york they
went head-to-head with the mob
and first al ruddy's car was shot up in
beverly hills
and there was a note on the windshield
saying you know they didn't want the
movie made
then there was something called the
italian-american civil rights league in
new york that was headed by a gentleman
named joe colombo
and he was fighting for
what he saw against what he saw as
stereotyping of italian americans in
popular culture and the godfather became
quite a quite a target that they wanted
to stop in the beginning
but and
what happened was the permits were
not able to be
you know permits didn't happen locations
didn't come through uh peop truck
drivers were threatening not to to work
on the film until already met with
the leaders of the league joe colombo
and his associates and what they wanted
was one word to be taken out taken out
of the script and that was mafia which
they did
and uh it was a simple excision for a
world of cooperation and pretty soon the
doors open to the movie and uh and the
rest is history and of course the
supreme irony there is joe columba
really was a mobster he was a mob boss
who has heading this organization to
protest the unfair stereoty typing of
italians as mobsters but he was a
monster wasn't he was he was one of the
another incredible character uh in this
whole in this whole story
and actually he was uh you know
when the movie was act was filming in
new york they were filming a scene of
the saint regis and joe colombo was
having uh leading a rally in columbus
circle
and he was shot
shot down by a would-be assassin he
lived for seven years but uh you know
and coppola had said you know
it was like you know life imitating art
just his art had imitated life and he
couldn't he he thought it would you know
he said i can't believe these people go
around shooting any like this anymore we
thought that those days were over but
indeed it was not
the uh you write in in great detail
about the battles for to cast the movie
and who was going to be in what role and
francis coppola had his own
ideas right from the get-go but suddenly
you got all these real-life mob guys uh
offering to to sign up and some of them
sort of leaning on it and and
threatening that they'd better get in
the picture right
yeah everybody wanted to be in the movie
after that point uh you know
as i said before with 750 extras at that
wedding you know you can count on some
some people getting in
i was also able to interview the uh the
new york casting uh
the director who cast the extras and he
told tales of like getting uh a scene
out of puzzles novel he said there was a
fish wrap that was delivered to him uh
you know from someone interested in the
role
and uh other stories like that and so
yeah everyone wanted to be in that movie
i mean but coppola francis koppler the
director saw the his cast from the very
beginning he saw
al pacino as michael he saw sunny
uh being played by james khan
and he saw you know tom hagan
being played by robert duvall and he saw
diane keaton as k
adams but and he brought them all to new
york to san francisco where he was
living he brought them all to san
francisco where he was living his wife
gave them haircuts and he did a homemade
screen test
and you can see those online but uh the
studio had different
ideas on who would play who robert evans
had different ideas and so they went
through hugely expensive
and intensive screen tests of almost
every actor in town
only to end up with the cast that kaplan
envisioned from the start the names that
are thrown around i'm putting them in in
the movie version that's playing on my
head and i just can't imagine it being
the same i mean robert redford was
mentioned for the michael corleone part
right exactly robert redford was one
ryan o'neal who was in love story for
paramount which was a huge hit for
paramount was considered as michael but
the big big big big uh battle was over
marlon brando nobody wanted marlon
brando except for puzzle at first puzzle
wrote to marlon brando uh he wrote a
letter in his distinctive hand and at
the top he put his current address that
said north carolina fat farm where he
was reducing and he wrote dear mr brando
you're the only actor who could play the
godfather uh with the quiet intensity
the role requires and kappala felt the
same way that brando was was born for
this role but brando was 47 and he was
considered washed up in the industry he
was considered problematic on the set
and nobody wanted brando and they had to
really fight to get marlon brand up you
write about this incredible scene where
brando transforms himself into don
corleone and at that moment it
alleviated all concerns about whether
he's right for the movie
exactly yeah so they uh you know
the head of paramount said
you know okay we'll consider it finally
we'll consider brando but he has to to
agree to us certain terms including do a
screen test and no brando would never
have done a screen test but kaplan
called it a makeup test we're just going
to come up to your house and fool around
and so they arrived one morning coppola
a cinematographer named hiro narita and
a few assistants and brando walks out
he's got a ponytail he's wearing a
kimono and this is the classic tale of
the godfather that he pulls back his uh
ponytail he puts some shoe polish on his
upper lip stuck some kleenex in his
cheek says i want to talk like a bulldog
and before they're rolling cameras
becomes the godfather
in such a dramatic fashion that they
they're you know they can't believe it
they were stunned into silence on the
way back
kapla goes directly from
los angeles to
uh charlie blue darn who owned the
studio golf and his company gulp and
western known paramount and he took the
footage to blue door and showed it to
him in his office and he goes he
couldn't believe it and everybody was
just as stunned and that footage uh won
brando the role and then that footage
disappeared from the face of the earth
nobody knows where it is to this day
uh
you know always think of it like
hemmingway's letters on this train
station in paris you know
that were lost but not his letter but
hemingway's uh first stories that were
lost in the guard of leon the train
station in paris
it's just a lost artifact that would be
so amazing to see
i've seen the movie probably 40 times i
guess it's magnificent i mean if i have
a it doesn't matter what my list of best
movies are but it's certainly at the top
and it's hard to to say uh godfather two
where that is on the list but they're
just such a great
it's such a great project and has stood
the test of time and
um i wonder how does coppola francis
coppola feel about it today looking back
at it now what a moment it was
yeah you know he didn't think it was
after
he had so many wars and battles and
you know as i write is discussed in the
book it was just a battle for him from
day one and uh peter bart who was uh
robert evans right-hand man at paramount
during those days wrote that it was like
all these tensions came together it was
like you know the war of the corlea
ownings was nothing compared compared to
the war of the men and women who made
the godfather because at every moment
they thought that francis koppel thought
he was going to be fired al pacino
thought he was going to be fired there
was an insurrection among uh the crew
who worked for coppola
coppola and his film uh cinematographer
had differing opinions at some point um
and so kampala left the set which was
hellish and went to paris where he was
writing uh the screenplay for the great
gatsby again for paramount and he didn't
know it was a success he would later say
until his wife called him uh and she
goes
he was in a hotel and she goes you won't
believe it francis it's a phenomenon
and he uh
only then
you know discovered it was such a huge
success so
you know it was a great achievement and
it was it announced him as one of the
great directors of
of american and international cinema
paramount which was as you write was
really on the skids on on thin ice it
needed a miracle this movie gave it to
him they got did i get this right twelve
thousand five hundred dollars is what
who sold the movie rights for
that yeah that's what he that's what's
been said of course as i write in the
book robert evans said that puzzle came
to him with his pages tucked under his
arm and evan said in trouble he goes
hand how he needed some cash for you
know his uh
the the bookies or whoever he owed money
to he said this is evans's portrayal so
we don't know exactly it was true or not
he says okay i'll give you 10 10 grand
he goes well can you make it 15 and evan
says what about 12-5
and uh so that was evans take but then
peter bart later said that the pages
came to him not evans other people said
they saw it first so it's just one of
those uh
crazy stories that has a different uh
different viewpoints from different
people what's the line you use in the
book about uh you know success as many
fathers
in this case it's many godfathers i
guess a lot of people take credit for
the for the movie being such a
phenomenal hit
exactly so something like success has as
many fathers as godfathers or something
like that yeah every you know of course
i mean so many people worked on this
movie and so many people added to its
magic i mean you know the horse-headed
scene with john marley
uh you know the
luca brassie scene that was done by
being a first-time actor who was
actually a professional wrestler uh you
know he just it was so majestic as luka
brassie lenny montana was his name
uh you know fredo uh
the third the son who uh was was you
know just magical he had never been in a
big film at that point uh john cazal
who would go on to oscar nominations and
so much glory and fame i mean all of
these unlikely
pieces came together in this masterpiece
and it's just it it's just amazing that
it even happened and who knows if it
could happen again it's just one of
those movie stories that are just you
know they created this piece of magic
that will live forever
uh james khan was not italian but he had
grown up and uh i think queens and he
knew mob guys he got to know him even
more during the making of the movie uh
he was perfect for sonny don't you think
oh he was so great uh he he he knew
these people he was from queens he's
been around him all of his life he said
he grew up in a neighborhood where
there were not that many actors or
artists but there were a lot of thieves
and uh he said that he bought uh these
one thing that he did say he was stuck
on a scene
and he just felt that he wasn't you know
into it and then he thought of you know
las vegas is one of las vegas great
comedians don rickles and he thought um
you know he remembered rickles and how
rickles would just you know it's you
know say things immediately in this
explosive way and that's how he he
informed the character of sonny and you
can see that in the scr on in his
performance also he went to a next to
new shop i think he said and he bought
these tight shoes uh they were like too
tight for him two-tone shoes and that's
how he uh you know facilitated tony's
kind of
i mean uh feels that his facilitated
sonny's walk and that gate you know
where he's walking around and strutting
around so he really used uh real life
people that he knew
to create this iconic role one of the
other actors that you write about was a
it was this first role is johnny russo
who's a las vegas character of
considerable renown and i've met him you
know 30 years ago had a nightclub here
shot a couple of people i remember him
being on our news set and pulling a gun
out of his holster and putting on the
desk and uh but he lobbied for the the
role uh of carlo and he made his own
film right he owned his own little sort
of a uh
yeah video he made his own audition film
yeah gianni russo uh
i don't believe he'd appear he had he
had a las vegas show though welcome to
my uh lifestyle right
and a nightclub johnny russo state
street uh club i believe that may have
been after the godfather but i don't
believe he had been in a motion picture
as an actor and
wow he was so great and he uh you know
he created this tape where he played all
three roles and he had it delivered to
our ruddy in los angeles and uh but you
know as i write in the book nobody was
quite sold on him until he convinced
everyone that he was right for the role
he uh i think he it was the scene where
he in one of those violent scenes with
connie corleone that he acted out in one
of the paramount offices and uh he was
pretty convincing in the role
yeah he's i mean he grew up he knew
those mob guys the last time i talked to
him i told you an email he was calling
from the apartment that was owned by
frank costello he says frank costello
the mob boss gave it to him
that's true
wow that's incredible and then you write
about um
the the cast really bonded that brando
far from being divisive and
temperamental sort of bonded with duvall
and khan and they all kind of hung
together
yeah the great story is the kabbalah had
the you know the genius to
uh bring the cast together as a family
over an italian dinner
at patsy's uh italian-american
restaurant in new york and brando headed
the table and talia shire
as connie was helping with with serving
and
uh
and uh
you know khan was there
uh
al pacino i believe was there
everyone was there it was like
from that point on the characters
existed couple later wrote because he
brought them together as a family and
they felt like a family they looked up
to brando they
they did everything together and as you
can write some of the hijinks that
happened on the set
uh
were quite quite hilarious and you know
brando was just you know
charismatic and everyone loved him it
seemed yeah they scene that's now in my
head permanently as brando mooning the
rest of the cast are at the wedding
scene right yeah
yeah well they said they said that they
had a a moon contest uh i think your
your viewers will know what mooning is
uh so i don't have to explain it that uh
you know they were on
after their first rehearsal they were on
one of the main streets of new york and
someone moon brando
it was either khan or uh hey or uh
robert wall and uh
and uh
brando
then they later had a moon contest at
brandon moon to catch a cast at the
wedding or something that's what that's
what's been written i don't know how
much of that is true
it's a great book filled with great
stories wonderful detail leave the gun
take the cannoli i recommend it to
everybody thanks very much for joining
us
thank you so much george it's great
being here and i'll talk to you again
soon couple weeks
[Music]